vincent matton bonsoir tué peintres
dessinateurs sculpteurs cinéastes
photographes
et sur ton passeport il a marqué c'est
vrai ça fabricant d'image
[Applaudissements]
tout ça quand même très mal commencé
parce que en 64 fait une expo et à
l'époque c'était la dictature de
l'abstrait il a été sur des chats qui
galèrent fota pas été franchement bien
accueilli sap a été un échec auprès des
gens qui vont acheter les tables à
l'époque ça a été un échec c'est vrai
auprès de la critique aux prêtres et aux
gens
qu'ils me voyaient à l'époque au travers
d'une
gris qui se voulait non figurative y
avait une discrimination à l'égard de
tout ce qui n'était pas simple
total était resté vingt ans sans
exploser j'ai continué à peindre mes
tympans qui va changer de nom on est
obligé de changer non oui battage pour
vivre travail était légal et yelp
askenazy la fin du stage est fait
l'illustration de presse pendant très
longtemps
mais parallèlement à ça j'ai continué à
peindre son sander quoi sans le dire
sans le temps de cacher sans éprouver le
besoin de mûrir est ce que je savais que
je rencontrerai sûrement d'une audience
auprès d'une sorte de gens mais qu au
niveau du marché j'avais aucune chance
de
de pénétrer le marché est illustrateur
de pub ça fait du beau coup j'ai fait sa
route après un gp de la presse je
travaillais avec le magazine français
est depuis très longtemps avec espoir et
la grande aventure américaine
j'ai un contrat d'exclusivité pendant 7
ans 6 ans avec good et lagarrigue
absolument ça fait du cinéma j'ai fait
du cinéma italien des roses il doit
faire du cinéma mais l'italien
desrochers quelque chose quand un
premier film à bohringer et son premier
thé pas vraiment il a connu comment dans
un bistrot bien sur wii dans un discret
les connu dans une boîte de nuit où j'ai
tourné un court-métrage est l'opérateur
et étienne decker et il avait un espèce
de temps jeu comme ça qu'il a braqué sur
richard qui était en train de danser les
yeux fermés très somnambule y est
vancouver les jeux j'aime bien me garder
il était fou de rage il doit foncer
dessus et heureusement ils tiennent me
koné serait ouais ils étaient copains
depuis 13 ans pour les bus très amis
déjà le projet du film quand il a
rencontré j'avais le projet d'un cours
d'un court métrage et lui ça comment
dire c'est ce qu'ils disent est ce
comportement
nuit qu'on a passé ensemble nous ont
donné envie de faire un bon départ est
revenue sur le devant de la scène avec
des maquettes et à dire que tu joues à
la poupe même avant
c'est parce que je n'irai pas le nom
parce que à dire vrai je considère moi
ces maquettes comme d'abord le point de
départ de ma quête ça a été ça n'a pas
du tout été dans l'intention de les
montrer je veux m'en servais pour en
faire disons que je voulais intervenir
sur la réalité de comme j'aurais pu
intervenir sur la toile tout ensuite la
photographier et donc obtenir une
photographie qu'il s'essaie n'est qu'une
photographie puisque c'est bien j'avais
sculpter les fauteuils d'un guéridon les
mains et c'est donc toutes les décisions
cultural été prises des contenus est
prise aujourd'hui préalablement et donc
l'image photographique obtenu d'un n'est
pas à proprement parler il photographie
allemagne et celle pour le procédé
photographique du revenu mais peu à peu
je me suis pris au jeu de la
reconstitution qui devait une fin en soi
c'est d'une précision diabolique
les appeler ça une structure il ya quand
comme j'avais un tableau sur un mur y'a
la trace du tableau qu'on a enlevé taf
un drive-in il ya plein de petites
bagnoles comme moi qui sont de la taille
d'une d'une phalange et elles sont
toutes des peuples même le pam en
créateur tu à 2400 fauteuil à 2400 il ya
un écran sur lequel tu projettes est
filmé par un écran s'inquiètent
disons que vos yeux pour
offert un satisfaction mégalomaniaque de
voir projeté sur l'écran d'un cinéma de
rêve mais petit film quand un artisan
juin artisans lundi travailler au
progrès de l'artiste aux progrès de la
wii la notion de progrès en armes et
m'échappe un peu je veux dire
on parle qui comptait vraiment jeu
maintenant avec le retour au figuratif
oui ah oui sam sarr ça me c'est vrai
qu'on a attendu son tour la figuration
durant
longtemps mais ça n'a pas exclu la
notion d'avant garde
elle demeure cette émission d'avant
garde et
elle existe aussi dans une passe savante
accueil chez les pros actuelle le tout
n'est pas réglé pour moi parce que mon
point de vue quand même c'est que
l'avait pas fait pour inventer il n'est
pas fait tellement pour s'exprimer soi
même il était de témoigner des choses
pour donner du plaisir aux gens
pour donner du plaisir et surtout faire
comprendre plaisir aussi
et si on comprend on a du plaisir
l'intérêt de ton système c'est qu'il
n'ya aucune décision picturale qui est
irréversible c'est à dire que tu peux
changer la lumière tu peux ce qui était
impossible quand j'avais loupé il peut
changer la place d'un objet tu peux
changer la lumière tu peux faire tout ce
que tu veux absolument divin que
j'utilise la photographie un peu comme
j'imagine les fans de la renaissance
utilisée lors leurs ateliers y avait des
gens qu'il est débarrassé toutes les
tâches trop trop longue et qui qui
interviennent avant d'attaquer vraiment
le
le coeur du sujet et c'est évident ça
doit être il était le metteur en scène
ils ont vu leurs ateliers et il y avait
une comment dire une
une une production de l'image est
absolument impensable s'il avait bu
[Musique]
peindre tout ça mais on peut voir autant
bull en ce moment en ce moment j'expose
dans le cas d'une exposition qui
s'appelle
l'invention d'un art qui est une
exposition dans le propos est de montrer
justement les relations qui entre la
peinture et la photographie depuis nous
mêmes les conservateurs à l'insa yaga a
eu l'idée que je trouve très fort
présente vicieuse à savoir de d'affirmer
et de le prouver que la peinture était
la photographie était d'une certaine
manière annoncé par les peintres du
début du 19e
donc avant l'invention de la
photographie des gens étaient soumis les
tensions oui mais il ya une baisse de
pression est donc l'exposition en
question retrace tout ce parcours j'ai
la dernière salle où g
une installation qui
il s'appelle la reconstitution
scrupuleuse de l'accrochage d'une
exposition à venir
c'est à beaubourg faut le dire d'abobo
si on devait donner une définition de
toi parce que sagan a donné une très
belle elle a dit c'est un grand peintre
pour une petite planète je ferais pas
mieux avant des corrections de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux